officer Cooper who stands at four feet
11 inches on come on the other suspect a
45 year old Latino but it is highway
Maddie I know you are
yeah you all want it I'm a police
officer mrs. Riva she's a federal
witness in my protective custody
oh I am protected by a meter me
everybody in the state is looking for
her Oscar burn dirty cops and the cartel
we need a couple hours to lay low kind
of like your smile Oh cut it out
he'll kill me before they let me testify
right now we can't trust anyone but each
other
I'm calling the cops they tried to
seduce me with some lesbian stuff and
her lover favorite position she wanted
me like in a big way like it like she
had like a breast boner I don't know if
you've ever seen that you're gonna get
killed off or some [ __ ] I need the
sparkly stilettos to go out and I need
the sparkly stilettos when I stay in and
I need the korky wedges all of Texas law
enforcement is looking for these two
working ok mcdeere noises are you
kidding me it's not a [ __ ] it is from
the horse family has been set up shot
honey
you don't know anything about me I have
seen your underwear do you wanna stay in
my head it's got its place in the paddle
is Nicki filtered oh you have to stop
treating me like I'm some rookie cop who
doesn't know what she's doing
you have to stop treating me like I am a
criminal that is this white stuff
more bikers toast muffins cakes loving
sex Niska be all jacked up we need a
different identity somewhere do you look
like Jose beaver you listen girl see ya
yo soy Miguel I'm totally crushing us
dude oh yeah that's your average got
chest yeah yeah that's right nothing
there